since the first league of Legends World
Championship in 2011 there's only been a
single team that has attended them all
and that team was team solomid so to
celebrate TSM 7th straight appearance at
Worlds we decided to put together the
best plays by TSM at Worlds starting
with this to be one outplayed by
Reginald this could be a very very dead
anni same [ __ ] going for it here they
come here's the flash and the oh here
comes tons of damage up when flash goes
out but it Wow
one each still picked up great play
there on both sides looks like there
comes the gank from Alice trapped at the
top rain man probably not going to do
too much actually playing aggressively
could be thinks he's alright and Twisted
Fate will he jump in no case I'm gonna
still just run around solo and rake not
in a good place there comes Kassadin
finally rake looks like he'll make it
out and now the rain man's gonna be
chased down can't they get enough done
with this oh he's diving into the turret
really gonna fling off in time to me
with silence break can you get away can
you get away can you get away nope bling
juice he's gotten that kill there's the
kill me from that Kassadin unless they
get unless they could kill yellow star
yet they shouldn't be able to know they
actually have enough damage over yes of
course
especially still that Trudy what that
means he has enough damage off of the
quickly Rocky's Ashe there that job is
gonna wow he's gonna go down he's not
gonna go down amazing he may go don't
know haha
he gets Kali or rather Reginald is the
chase right now for shine the flash over
and he's just gonna walk through the
file happily the exhaust goes down that
single target damage is going to be a
lot of burst and Reginald is really
trying to do what he can before going
down but biding time for Team his team
to do other things Requiem on two sides
Andy sighs go Todd
one in the jungle this sign no new duck
has taken a narrative path he puts a
wall down will ulti also up nope don't
look at that damage bull comes in from
darkness he sidesteps oh wow even
finishing up the kill there in the anton
newcombe Zorro zero gonna chase him now
get side kill but in the meantime bottom
Lane answer it taken there ITSM and the
5b 45 here comes wild turtle creare
going down but he's not gonna be a
nothing touches the couch that's right
that's gonna be one kill em PI goes down
and there's gonna be candy get up
towards him know he's gonna cross walls
he's visible the double kill the poison
take you just have to give up at that
point the teleport was completely wasted
gsm had a monster spell or as no escape
and sk just make matters worse
Wow Julius going down cheston's in the
wrong place
in the cloud that's also why lupus say
I'm not gonna go for them this time
stick if you see something that says I
want to doing very well as they're
making sure they have a lot of people in
the bottom lane in case TSM decides to
go for a dragon soon here before all the
heirs are very low
thus our finding you out baby kill your
pink boards that kind of stuff is
working out for us in for a critic or JJ
plenty damage on to the pumpkin step
back onto ruler nicely trade it flirts
the exhaust and that lookin screwed it
up the house and was gonna take the
curse now Bob Ross blocks away sonic
wave Ward hop the sonic wave connects
Karen follows him over the wall but it
makes cheese running a mile a minute oh
yeah
flash forward sonic wave Skara gets the
kill the recipients of another dive no
flash available for Spain but a good
stand from the slicing maelstrom this
should be a relatively easy kill unless
semi like she can get involved looking
at the mini-map Xiao who's coming up
from the jungle and space demon travel
on slots of Shadows available he jumps
out but Fred gets away this is a really
strange game dude I've seen Smith's
Karen has found there's the shock wave
that was exceptional firing shots in the
enemy team ray takes a lot of damage of
us if always gone to ruler and chunk sit
down and watch board really what
security does
what the cam down is op TSM Olynyk for
the bottom turret not ton actually
bjergsen gonna check out the obvious
crowd fairly short satanic eruption bit
quite the hella get out of this one
let's find out crown Gideon Octavia
Spencer keeps him in a fire from Fox is
here as well he pushes the wall but
double it troops in to clean him up as
Hornsey gets credit it takes some good
coordination to pull off a waffle combo
but TSM makes it look easy with this
brutal CC chain against next Peck a you
can still technically collapse it it's a
lot harder to gasp baby didn't want to
take that chance but with our hamburger
submission it earlier it's done it's
this one no ash cocoon and they take
down expecting Wheatley under that
turret but then it's gonna be up to
analysts are here there's the bump the
pulverize she is off and she is going to
go down right there
very nice job and collective coming out
of the hands of TSM and mata can't get
out going down pawn throws himself into
the front there but they close upon the
most expensive of the members actually
the play as well they forced a flash out
of him and he's down to about 310 HP in
range four shots of the turret shows
dyrus here what they definitely want
they bring out the flyswatter and take
down dandy [ __ ] [ __ ] funky to commit
to one course of action and the closer
that kid seems to be 100 ante dropping
Timbers right out of sausage sauce he
goes down onto the turret or right under
the turret I should say and this turret
will go down watts wonder it forces the
flash out now the flash taste he's got
that one in the picture fighting games
and all the damage they could possibly
need and finally TSM finds blood mega
gnar was away yes here comes second hour
but it's not the most beautiful put some
to wonder minute damage the
follow-through it's already 2 and the
turret nearly falls as well ooh maximum
width that already be two teams of three
and from CSS perspective they need to be
strong at this stage of the game and
they've already knocked down to one
member for the turrets gonna be up next
it can't even run away so rolling over
spices Oh coffee gets head from the
deadly flourish and maybe just best dose
Alton good 5 doublelift on a killing
spree now and look at the mega gnar
catches several splice variants
that's several more look at that a340
the blink of an eye he is on a as
hopeless the ouster dive he can't do
anything to Freddie
so why not go mid for jests right into
the wall will stop him up for a little
bit longer the synergy comes in from the
bat POW just ignited Genesis town
Reginald was once one of the best mid
laners in the world and there was no way
he was going to let epic gaming's West
Rice get the better of him in there's
1v1 battle from the season one world
championships and they both escaped
really aggressively recent changes make
their doctors need stud Cohen justanna
kind of stupid
any any damage per minute is like oh
yeah I would kill you before you kill
you that was yeah that was just enough
them to stay a while using their skills
their advantage and this high tier play
able to do some escapes a very nice job
with the ultimate it looks like you
could do a bit of damage will you be
able to take him down going for the
transfusion and he does very nice and we
see that it almost pretty pretty much
canceled his ultimate I would give that
edge though to TPA because it was GSM we
spent the extra time on Dragon and the
mid laner he got for his butt but if he
gets it right back divers has been
getting himself into somewhat d1
situations but he's coming out on the
topside pushing then gets a big wave
before I was down for something he got
the way from all things you can say that
was not a good decision once in on the
doublelift how's that duel gonna go
charges 1q looks and dodge the next one
because he's getting pushed into view
likes a higher spell damage you hole in
OT does do it for a crowd
TSM and clg's robbery goes as far back
as League of Legends itself so it's no
surprise that when they met in the 2011
World Championship that it would lead to
an explosive team fights the both is
Prakash watch EG and that did save the
rain man as he's gonna get crushed right
there and Reginald jumping into the
fight and there is the egg for big cut
off feed Sona dance comes out look
signifi is going to drop first Warwick
now the next one to died he's getting
into bad shape Jarvan jumps onto
malzahar miles Morgan her real
look at the damage output soda next went
up and how does a Ford an up and kill
score right there
TSM completely crushing that fight and
saucy and West rice is 305 the a show
coming out on to tumble if that's
exactly where they wanted to hit and
they will be able to take one out is
their inhibitor responds they feel a
little bit more confident about this
fight that Dan did will throw down the
ultimate trying to focus on to Reginald
as well as the chaox chaos like a huge
damage to the timber misses as he
flashes out of that one great reflexes
by chaox understanding the timing of how
Andy wanted to do that saucy
taken down by the hands of Rain Man and
it looks like this fight is actually
going in favor of Team solomid dyrus
looks like he could go down here he will
continue to do the damage he can until
the fight happens and a very nice job
looking offer all this free damage the
crescendo cleansed out on that one
by the Quicksilver I believe and it
looks like the fight will be huge it's
going to be all the damage going to Team
solomid they have hardly any house but
they're still engaging it looks like a
zoop rust is on their heels here but
they have quite a bit of a detail they
leave shy alone and TSM with a sliver of
house is just able to out position in
the fight the super cross forced out of
that one somehow can out of there and
there's a special close fall comes in
it's gonna be a double killing its neck
special of pics of both up and now
they're in trouble and special stanley
90 comes out dyrus is gonna join the
body exhaust use on towards dandy
brother special still just about getting
away from this one you know your son you
know he was actually captain's we
checked that out the moment Andy
breathing
thank you down how deviate all of his
own on the tower he's going to get drop
there's no way out of it and it's gonna
be another double kill but while total
eight one two now on the ad carry no
one's waiting behind someone waiting odd
weren't gonna waltz in Nuuk don't you
see Sonya's will he be able to escape
there is surah zero coming down a big
fight going on and Reginald dives into
the fat take some warm coke can they get
more yes or a zero South Sydney won't
escape now they chase down fixer as well
he'll be locked up they be stopped by a
double kill they're from Reginald and
that in four kills maybe even a bit the
attack very low this could be the
explosive fight move waiting for as long
as fists can get a flank what for
what a nice equaliser down the choke of
that little rate path it's insect
getting hit up very hard can amazing
finalise the kill
it's gonna be the shot coming in from
wild turtle going to the backside
garrison he gets the trickster damage
sonia doubt the double kill for turtle
Pearson goes down but he takes down
court first a double as well Peruzzi
he's trying to keep him stop
who's going to try to waltz out of this
one is amazing distracts him wild turtle
could go win the game they have super
minions and amazing just needs to stop
the recall let's see what if we gotta
have a fight earlier on frustratingly
efficient but let's see how it works
level one 5v5 he doesn't go down Samsung
white is running through hell picking up
the kill yes M does not look like they
can even get past him no everything's
used to just get Pyo Lowe analogy DSS
right now our dairy arrests actually
coming in at mega gnar's up against the
wall TSM will be able to start feeding
this one up infinite bad spot he finally
gets cleaned up by wild turtle and
Turtles double kill hopefully getting
him excited for a triple kill hear
exactly what team solomid needs the
Quadra kill the right target is the one
that distorts obviously so they know
where to go but TSM wins a fight like
this and they are getting anything else
on the map we're gonna try and fight
this one if there's 7,000 gold advantage
there's the ulti outlaw boy looking for
a book fine Zico with the Dragons
already dead but get a breakout center
our jumps in five years little too sir
those
rabisu the black the first kill has a
prediction rather fun trying to get
absolute gonna join him sent or no way
around the back here gonna get knocked
himself away sin throwing us to get out
a good result him self-esteem you kids
looking for dessert and get the first
kill that should be enough go keep
chasing two icons gonna run in for
support world total pops is gone is but
the damage is just massive if tearing
through the team they really are LGD
they are losing one or two though they
found wildturtle
as well as Santorum Tyrus will survive
the bleed will keep Tyrus a double kill
I think that was a gold card to find
another three members ability is not
Charlie's gonna look for the ulti does
not come in I think it's gone mid
instead ear does you something go around
the back just in the inhibitor let's get
a chance there we go tires straight on
the mid inhibiting the mental age is
gonna go down and look at the minion
wave up top yikes and has teleported to
fight any corn lgt our second game this
group stage which he beacuse been cure
tiles there goes for it yes and it's not
going to hit know there's an all people
knock take away your exit massive damage
legendary twist events get it clean out
one tbq can be in trouble as the stars
are coming out him
everybody gets exhausted we finally fans
they want the fight to JOA come away
everybody now now let's see Tyrus he's
in trouble he gets taken down coffee in
him still alive
what points to TSM Seiko maybe it's now
fire crosses in trouble he gets down the
fish
solo
[Applause]
going in he's going to watch make you
again not gonna land the roof but they
are gonna get this snipe the
assassination Mickey goes down five feet
for Miss connote Smith back into a
strategy Pearson Bernadette pops the
shield and Rex they won't get the kill
look at the damage out from wonder
they've picked up one lose his life as
well the equalizer
turning a fight around isn't easy but
when your team Oh needs help you make
sure to come to his rescue and TSM does
just that in this place as dyrus begins
to come into the lane that W of T Mago
Oh deep to the lane huh bushes can't see
me I'm gonna run by oh just getting out
of range of the flick now he does cuts
it because the alternate is gonna give a
little more speed will he be able to do
it he can
the ultimate coming down from Dan Ted
looks like they will be able to drop the
rain man here the damage being done by a
full product absolutey no Danton Falls
the very nice job coming in by the hands
of TSM the odd one to really shut down
what was about to happen come down from
that middle area we actually see them
starting to move as quickly as possible
away and there goes Kevin nailed to the
water tower
absolutely ridiculous burst there fall
down bottom Lane it looks like they're
gonna be quite aggressive around two
especial the Ignite goes down know the
grievous wounds on to a special rather
and they will force this one madlife
just on the back side can you get a
power fist and there it is
they could be going special the second
kill comes in Requiem takes down
and here comes the odd one the generals
to set up a kill for chaos and he
actually takes it for itself they are
going to push TSM out of there the ward
is just giving them too much control of
this position they get a kick out of
madlife the doubt that goes down they're
not able to take back out of the
beautiful : that way for sure looking
out for first blood he passes away and
the general thinking of blue and they
kill blue pours down the fight as well
nothing else is happening for TSM that
was a brilliant move by oMG getting it
down wild two little bow feet away from
that struggle force you can see the
crescendo of those big pomelo but sad is
tending this one around on his head
well tilt those get that kill that's
gonna be the passive income a low on
swords an ex-special and this is a walk
along we talked about the power it is
very very close Oh aren't we there he
doesn't have any hole and they aren't
one pounces to finish off the kill dyrus
in the meantime is gonna have faker
knocking on his back door he's coming
straight in there uses the exhaust on
impact but he's not gonna be enough
hasn't got the damage down and in fact
is the tower damage gonna come down it
just might on it red wheels gonna go
down yes he's doubled on the bottom just
down the pits also
Wow Toma picks it up a 10-7 suddenly to
301 way cannolis the fight of a
disengaged iris doesn't know though the
brush control from TPA here to the top
lane but amazing on my in a back pocket
he gets the cripples out he's able to
lock it it's hot he goes down for first
blood and they cook here wins here Clem
spit her out but they're gonna back off
white gets arrogant again it opens
commits but they're so far ahead right
now there's a pretty good chance
pretty nice turn them beyond the feed
sins does not strike he doesn't have to
em takes them down first but it does put
him in a position to be a menace here on
the backside the fight
nice calling to come out fee he'll
summon are used by the turn a triple or
double kill rather coming in here for
amazing intervention turns this one
around
he wants those bonds but he does not get
him his wild turtles able to seal the
deal on that kill place your fish you
might get needed the wall comes up and
be unbreakable shield Dustin
he's in trouble flashes away with his
life locked up by the keepers verdict
it's double is still trying to run down
the damage up to my ex g looper gets
bitten but the claims it's already
tagged eat the chair lupa he's rude
president placed under the tower looking
at the part here comes the play
equalizer gets a little bit of damage on
officer but plainly could have a name
better by cuvee PSN was ready for it is
they knew to disappear at the counter
teleport comes out three versus three
how good is it gonna be Gibson is in
doesn't get us done just yet but funny
damage onto ambition facing Nelson comes
through they will kill off the rack side
one four zero and now double it versus
crown plan for us to help the going
knocks him down gets late for everything
else with Spence good right here says
get to South cuz he knew he was close
really good read no thinking damage over
he's actually gonna come back GameCube a
is under the tar but he's actually just
that arranged and spend the minions
might even look back in four minutes -
its Garrett can he do it again
[Applause]
fiction to his death now spends in a
little bit of trouble here because
there's still some tell Brian good Pombo
in that will pay the prices rule against
the trade CSM has had a few objective
steals in their world championship
history but this unbelievable steel
against oMG in the 2013 World
Championship is definitely one of the
most impressive the old one is close by
but I'm not sure he's gonna know he's
gonna have to go so so deep to try and
land this one he wants to get him get
this fight down he didn't get it he gets
this fight now for TSM well it was a
sacrifice but it was worth it as over
1000 go go ladies and get the steel
Rumble opals out look how it's
separating the fight right now they take
down insect John the waters that dyrus
the bed person he can throw the shield
over bjergsen odd he will go down though
zero with a beautiful man soon to keep
the fight going and yes
it's trying to recuperate here but it's
just too much damage coming in from
Royal Club now turtle joins the fight
does he have enough for the sustain to
still put up shots
he's fighting within the press to get
more headshots he's trying to do it he
can wildturtle stop turning out to the
dragon now how fast can they take off
whoa lustboy low helps doing this dragon
fifth dragon does it go
denied
this dragon tsm's best level one invades
coordinated tower dives and invisible
teemo's are all up next in our list of
the best set plays by TSM at world from
when they were in the jungle looks like
they're gonna be heading for a movement
right here on and they may be able to
get them there come Z at center a coming
up the hands of Andy the ice ball coming
out of the hazard if he is able to flash
from the wobble both of them class to go
after him and they will be able to grab
the first blood Reginald cog out with
that one and that's exactly who they
needed to get that one yeah wow wow he's
there it is the only thing coming out of
hands and knocks her and he will be able
to stay around the turret but it's not
going to do that much damage the one
it's focusing it was knocked hurt
himself they're able to come out with a
big kill there and they saw this being
detrimental last time no grabbing the
minion the go for him still
they got him caught up very well they
great positioning by chaos he can't even
pass through the bush just looking
towards that bush but again look at that
they came straight on top of him they
know his exact location this could still
be a little bit tricky though they get
it wrong in Suarez and also some trouble
this could be fun Reggie's just getting
himself into a whole Joe trouble here
though it's a hole how didn't he feel
him oh man he's not that furry I guess
he's covered in this right on top of him
he's got to be running on oxygen he's
gonna come out soon flag but they go
persona some of the lowest HP in the
beginning of the game all right
laughter Roger no but he goes down
valiantly GPA just strictly does not
have enough damage right now compared to
the defensive capabilities on TSM and
this is also what we need to see is the
teams are not afraid to keep going as
well they're gonna take down here a
little too far here comes score from the
side are they actually gonna fight this
I don't think so teleport coming in for
TSM tires and Pearson show up big naka
from Tyra's arrow gets back under turret
trying to do some damage here he's still
going for down Tyrus manages how Pearson
take him out and some day trying to do
it every Kent he's got one kill and a
wild turtle already turtle took out
score with the post-death finance of
explosion some day
acting under turret gotta get away lust
way nearly died there meanwhile now
ignite takes out that man some day
happens gonna quite work out for he's
gotta get this not actually in time just
barely now time for the knock up into
the stunt into the Unleashed power not
even needed it just have so much
pressure into lanes on sir yeah looking
for the stunt don't get the personal
boots and change the EQ back they're
gonna be the target eaten up another
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button